hope
um do you feel like you're above average
and what do you bring to an above
average woman
is a super arrogant to say but you know
for like the
to the average male in 2023 it's not
hard to be above average like if you
break it to categories like physically
spiritually career-wise friendship
relationship with family I feel like
physically
um I train every day so in that sense I
feel like I'm above average
um
you said the statistically about being
over six foot luckily I'm six one so
that's another thing above average okay
um in terms of career like I've had a
mad career I've achieved a lot I've got
a degree for my mum in case anything
else failed
um I've achieved all my goals I set out
in the modeling World um oh you're a
model yeah I've achieved I took me like
six years to achieve all of them goals
what did you do for the for the goals
and modeling so like for example like
when I was 24 I used to stand in that
Birmingham city center and look at a
billboard and before I ever did a photo
shoot my whole life and said one day I'm
going to be on there then it'd be like
International bookings then it'll be
stores in London then it'll be certain
brands I'd want to shoot for this and
that and then yeah I did them all and
they were all very like clearly written
out next to my bed I take them all off
as I go along yeah and then um
show so much gratitude along the way as
well so it's just like because you know
when you come from nothing like when you
have something it's like it's like the
best feeling ever so yeah in that sense
of what I could do in terms of that
spiritually I've been on my spiritual
journey found peace Within Myself I've
Revisited old stuff
um my communications everyone in
relationships things like this so I
think I bring a lot and the question you
asked earlier about when I'm like when I
speak to a female I ask them questions
and I say like what do you bring to the
table because I'm bringing XYZ
um but yeah now now I'm like I've kind
of like um
bulletproof my philosophies in in
regards to what I want in a relationship
so I very much know if this person is
going to be the one for me I feel like
that's the stage you might know that's
funny like everything you said was like
results oriented so you said you're
above average in looks and you but if
you model your top 20 looks roughly
because you wouldn't get a modeling
contract if you weren't yeah so I mean
that's that's like um is it subjective
and it's what Society dictates as well
what's like what's really fine no no
like if you look at dating app data
people tend to find the same types of
people attractive but there's some
people that would like hate tattoos or
some people don't hate I mean there's
like a little bit of subjectivity to it
but not really like a lot now okay yeah
but yeah in that sense and then when you
say like um I had this in my career like
you listed the accomplishment yeah yeah
it was just interesting because when men
answer they usually answer more like
results where it's like girls it's more
like feelings yeah yeah I feel that
do you think you're above average and
what do you bring to an above average
guy I think I have an average girl and
she said Tory it's a bit silly if we if
we don't grow there's always time to
grow there's always space for knowledge
um I grew up in a very religious
household so for me it is quite
naturally to submit once you understand
how things go it's not a bad thing like
it's not negative it's not toxic if
anything I feel like in this Society
this this modern world do you know how
powerful you are as a woman to submit in
this world you can be an animal if you
want to you have the freedom to say I'm
a I'm a slug and yet you choose to
submit for your man I find that very
powerful and there's nothing wrong with
that I feel like it makes sense there is
balance in the house he knows what to do
you know what to do and it just brings
nurture as well and you taught me that
as well oh thank you but I did grow up
in a in some kind of house okay so you
have a model of like a that's that's
that's something guys look for in your
family background for sure with my
family I'm not allowed to move out until
I get married really yeah I there's a
line that I can't I've heard I've heard
guys say that's like a green flag where
he's like yeah if she still lives with
her parents that's good I've heard guys
say if she like they look at your family
background to see if your mom submitted
to your dad yeah I'm actually 25. if it
gets like late I'll have a phone call
like where are you what time are you
coming to yes I live with my family too
when I was younger I didn't like it I
thought but now that I'm 25 I appreciate
it so much because I've avoided so much
I've avoided so much it's amazing yeah
so thank you my brother thank you Mom
thank you everyone honestly
um okay do you have anything else you
want to add to it if you live at home
you know you've seen a successful
relationship uh what else
um you don't cook I I I've I got forced
to learn how to cook I could almost
learn how to kind of hated it but now
I'm so thankful honestly what types of
food do you like to cook so I love Arab
food so for me it's all about the rice
and the chicken and the sauce
so I would say that yeah
but I don't mind learning other other
culture as well I don't really mind
could you date a man outside your
culture
um if you've got fearing yes for me you
need God in your life otherwise there is
there is just I don't think anything can
be successful but that's my opinion
because if you don't and the family
Family Mud because swim if you don't
respect your mom you're not going to
respect a stranger I ever went to what
religion are you so I grew up uh dad was
Christian mum was Miss Slim So I did
have both sides and love them both and
I'm I'm so happy that I had both because
it opened my mind as well
um yeah which one do you
um
they're so similar
they're so yeah that's so interesting
yeah they're so similar I used to
actually go Church churches a lot um uh
again I don't please it's just my
opinion um
you might I just didn't
understand how like um Jesus was God so
now when and then when I done my
research in Islam it was like he's a
prophet but so for me that made sense
and I thought okay like it answered my
question but they're just saying we need
to do good those tradition there is
respect for me
is the same I'm I'm curious because I've
noticed in Christian churches they're
kind of driving men out where there's
not a lot of young men in Christian
churches anymore it's like if you look
at them like if you go into a church
under like I don't know 35 ish it's
mostly women
um and I'm curious is are there more
young men in like Muslim religions
um from wampsi now there's a lot of
converts I feel like
um there's there's more happening now so
um yeah I think there's there's loads of
man in the mosque yeah because I think
it's one of the few religions that that
keeps traditional masculinity where
they're Christians are kind of they're
kind of gone yeah because back in the
days it was it was so similar but now
people are trying to make it so modern
and it's like you can't pick and change
yeah yeah and then they just like Pander
because most of the women are the ones
like paying into churches so the problem
is they just Pander to women yeah and
I've had like some Churches like you can
have gay marriages and stuff you can't
fake and shoes and the other thing is
they always have like what do they call
it um corn addiction groups for the men
but they never have social media
addiction groups for the women and it's
like they always like put out women on a
pedestal even if she's like ran through
and had two kids you should still wait
till you're married with her it's like
what are you what what
it's like something
okay I was just curious uh what about
you
um I know I'm average
um reason being is because I'm not a
wife yet I think the best way to measure
if someone is above average is to look
at their relationship status and I feel
like if a man hasn't signed some papers
and made a promise in front of God to be
with me forever and have kids with me
then that definitely means I am an
average woman it's like going into
singing competition and then you know
the judges Whitney Houston if Whitney
Houston tells me I am not good and that
means I'm definitely you know not above
average when it comes to singing so um
yeah in terms of my relationship status
I'm still single I haven't found anyone
who is you know ready to commit to me so
that means there's some things that I
need to improve on so yeah I'm average
and I'm happy about it it just goes to
show that I'm a work in progress and so
what you're gonna leave the value of
yourself in the hands of somebody else
not at the hands of someone else but
it's just you
for me personally I feel like for me
personally I feel like a person's
ability to maintain a relationship goes
to show just how good of a person that
they are it shows their compatibility it
shows their patience and it also mirrors
how a person can value them as well so
for me I think relationship is the best
way to measure so for example if I saw a
woman and she was 50 with six cats I
would think there's something really
wrong with that woman
who was like 20 and married like let's
be real the best way to measure how a
person is like when you see a female and
she has like no friends you would know
there's something wrong yeah yeah those
extreme examples are valid so I
definitely feel like the best way to see
how a person is you know a good person
is to see how they are with their
relationships and I feel like with me
marriages that epitome of like okay this
person is a good person so yeah I would
say until I'm married I definitely think
I'm above average I think that's an
interesting perspective I think you're
right because it's like you have to
judge based on your results so
but I think like you as a woman the type
of guy you can maintain says something
about you so it's going to be a quality
husband
I definitely agree with you in the sense
that like if you marry the wrong person
and that definitely means you're average
because how could you be so silly to not
realize what's best for you so in that
case but let's be real there's a lot of
marriages that have worked out and for
those that have worked that I definitely
think they are above average because
your ability to keep someone happy to be
patient to be compatible to provide for
them like for me when I think of above
average I think of someone who's
nurturing someone that can cook someone
that and when you package that that's
basically why female traditional
traditional women get scooped up by 25
the best women are gone by 25 out of the
dating Market because the best women
want a family and want kids and they
find the man that want a family and want
kids and they're gone if I could get
married tomorrow about absolutely weird
honestly honestly
um but I definitely feel like Society
has lost that importance of like
measuring someone by their relationships
without being said 100 agree of what you
were saying but
on the lower scale a man can come along
and be absolute trash let me just use
like all right cool so
the way that my dad has worked yeah um
he's got with someone and he's married
them and it's like okay she's not worthy
he's just settled down with her because
it's convenient do you get what I'm
saying so if she was to measure that by
oh yeah I'm great you're not great babe
you don't have a lot going on but he's
married you because he's getting old and
because all of these different factors
on the larger scale what you're saying
100 I agree with you and it makes sense
but there are the uh the lower
percentage of men that are low quality I
just want to make it clear I think what
I was trying to say is if you're in a
healthy marriage I'm not going to sit
here and say for God
right right that means no there's
definitely some circumstances where
there's people that are married and they
are below average because again they're
abusive or the guy has set order
whatever yeah yeah but for the healthy
marriages and there's is a lot of
healthy marriages
um it definitely goes to show your
ability to be in a above average person
and another thing I realized I feel like
a lot of people focus too much on the
negative I feel like the negative
situations of abusive partners and
whatever they're like a small percentage
women are more abusive than men in 2023
yeah I think there's more women that hit
men than men that hit women I just don't
think it's reported yeah I agree with
that because women hit men like in this
when they're angry and when they're
having arguments and they do like
pushing and shoving but the men just
don't retaliate so the thing is as well
for a man do you know how degrading it
is to bring up that your woman has hit
you exactly that you're not going to
bring that up you're just going to keep
it quiet yeah so a lot of women they
brag oh you know my man hit me a man
ain't gonna do that so it's very very
different and usually it's like the last
straw because you've actually got him to
that Peak at that point so he's had to
do something they also don't talk about
the women that get a man to a certain
point by verbally abusing him and then
he snaps one day and then they label him
as abusive or crazy when it's like you
what's worse being hit like the scars
heal but things that people say to you
you can't take that back
um and can I also say that like sorry
and even if you are like an average
woman I think what we need to understand
like it's actually okay to be average
that basically just means you're a
working person so for everyone here he's
probably like single this is not me
trying to say that there's like
something wrong with you you're probably
still a work in progress just like me
and I think that's something like us as
people need to learn to admit a little
bit rather than just having this mindset
of okay I'm a cat today so now I'm gonna
be a cow I'm a dog like let's you can be
realistic in the present so yeah to
answer that question because I was kind
of waffling I'm definitely average yeah
but I think you know when you said about
like we focus on the negative like for
me personally like someone might say oh
you focus on the negative because I'm
not like definitely Keen to have a get
married and have kids right now and I've
always been that girl that's like live
your life travel do what you want like
tell my friends to women young girls
that I mean I'm like I'm very much an
advocate for that and then people may
think oh it's because you've never had a
healthy relationship in your life or
you've not got that example actually no
my parents have been together since they
were 16 and they're married and I live
with them so I have had the best example
actually but I have the most realistic
example as well but that's a modern
mindset that's a below average mindset
which which what to travel and explore
the world and some men don't want that
yeah but why is it about what men want
because like men are the buyers you have
to learn the buyers in order to be
bought yeah but I I just I so strongly
disagree with that because I'm not going
to live my life depending on what a man
wants like you know and that's a below
average mindset that's a problem with
modern women but who's it is below
average the men um no man wants a girl
that won't live here okay that's our
skin anyway let's ask him you're a man
is that a below average mindset because
as a woman I feel like it's important to
you know take care of yourself first
when you're young at least not I'm not
talking when you're older I'm saying
you're like early 20s teens like travel
learn about yourself and don't Focus so
much on trying to get into relationship
and get married by 25.
no I disagree you know I think I'd want
to be the one that takes her on that
experience so she experiences with me
for the first time
so you think that's a below average my
answer I'm still going to stand on my
points
no I'm just telling you how men see it
and like Nancy if you traveling around
metamenci that as you're sleeping around
like man then I will just wait so men
see it if you're in a different in all
these different cities that you're
writing something in all these different
cities that's how men see it it's also
if you've been single for a long time
men see it as oh she's been doing she's
been doing something she's been up to
something like that's how the guy see
you as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible